Усього лише за три місяці жителі
окупованих районів Луганської і Донецької областей
зможуть отримати російське громадянство.
Згідно з указом, який опублікували на сайті Кремля,
охочі можуть подати заявку до підрозділу МВС Росії
та докласти до неї низку документів. Серед них -
посвідчення особи, видане окупаційною владою так званих "ДНР" та "ЛНР".
У посвідченні має бути відмітка про проживання на території регіону.
У МВС Росії заявили, що приймати ці заяви будуть
представники сепаратистських регіонів,
а розглядатимуть їх на території Ростовської області.
В Україні та на Заході крок Кремля засудили.
Його пов'язують зі спробою Росії контролювати сусідню країну.
Окрім того, це суперечить мінським угодам,
вважають політики. Так, у Берліні повідомлення
про указ Путіна сприйняли з занепокоєнням.
Чому Кремль наважився на такий крок саме зараз?
Опитані DW експерти припускають, що таким чином
Москва має намір якнайшвидше продемонструвати
новообраному президенту України Володимиру Зеленському,
що збирається розмовляти з позиції сили і
нав'язати свої умови переговорів.
- Це сигнал новообраному президенту України
Володимиру Зеленському про те, що Росія
контролює так звані "народні республіки", ухвалює
там рішення і в змозі почати ескалацію в регіоні.
І тим самим ускладнити Зеленському вихідні позиції
на переговорах. Але я не бачу, щоб у Росії була
кінцева мета, окрім як створити і підтримати в регіоні
ситуацію, подібну іншим "замороженим конфліктам".
Але поки я не бачу прагнення Росії анексувати
ці регіони або зайти далі, ніж зараз.
Із твердженням німецької експертки
згодні незалежні аналітики в Москві.
- Паралельно з цим відбувається, наприклад,
закриття поставок в Україну нафтопродуктів.
Тобто якісь недружні дії. Очевидно, що все це
пов'язане з ситуацією зміни влади в Україні і має
на меті вплив на нового президента. Тому що,
скажімо, інструменти тиску на Порошенка
були вичерпані, сформувався статус-кво,
було зрозуміло, що Порошенко в певних питаннях
ніколи не поступиться, в нього є позиція певна.
А зараз відчиняється вікно можливостей.
Українські експерти вважають указ Путіна
спробою тиску Кремля. Нині, за різними даними,
на непідконтрольній Києву частині Донбасу
проживають близько трьох мільйонів осіб.
- Продовження цієї політики Кремля, яка зазвичай
проводилася раніше по відношенню до
так званих невизнаних держав -
маріонеткових утворень,
квазідержавних утворень
на постряданському просторі, які є
інструментом політики Кремля.
Така політика проводилася у Придністров'ї,
в Абхазії, в Південній Осетії.
Зараз вона проводиться щодо окупованих територій України.
Київ уже звернувся з цього приводу до Ради Безпеки ООН
та закликав громадян, які проживають в окупованих районах Донбасу,
не подавати заяв на видачу їм російських паспортів.
Далі, вважають аналітики, багато що залежатиме
від того, що вирішать у Радбезі і якою буде
дипломатія України за нового президента:
обере Володимир Зеленський стратегію свого попередника Петра Порошенка,
прийме російські умови чи зможе вибудувати
нові дипломатичні відносини з Москвою.